warzone kings less than five seconds 68
players
1859 average rating here we go
played this guy in the last tournament
oh there was a mouse slip on his part
i remember that
oh i why'd i move my knight there
oh well
oh well
h6 bishop back
no we're having that
yeah there was a mouse slip in that one
okay the knight cannot move just yet
upon push my bishop is happy
upon pushing my bishop is happy and i
have something to bite out with f4
i want to support that
and give me the file i have the f file
all right
oh why'd i do that queen d2 first
i should have done queen d2
the knight's gonna jump in here maybe
let's stop that
let's get the dark square bishops off
the board why why would i back up my
bishop like that why would i do that my
bishop is dead i was caught in a
pre-move sort of
i was caught in a pre-move sort of
okay
yeah i should have met a5 with a4
let's do this can i get that pawn pawn
push that queen
bishop's gonna get kicked around
he is officially getting kicked around
and now okay now that rook has some play
on the a file i want my knight on d3
d3 pawn push
whoa that can't be right can it
defend stuff
trade grab that pun
i'm gonna take that everybody loves a
queen trade i love the queen trade
come on defend defend defend my rook
wants activity
here's the activity
activity
sneaky stuff happening sneaky stuff
happening no it's not happening oh it is
happening it's not happening
tricky stuff tricky stuff pre-moves
where are you at
let's just take that
watch out for the sneaky pond
give me the sneaky pun
ah
whoa i thought i lost on time i didn't
down to the wire
wow somebody has eleven
yes i have somebody to try and catch
silver flame seven
okay
i've had this position before where my
knight develops there and then comes
back home but now he could just get
there in a blink
bishop here his pawn is hit a lot of
times
let's get this out
i should maybe take him here first now
let's support my knight there might have
been g4 let's close it up
can i grab that pawn and get away with
it we're going to try
i'm going to try here
okay we're going to trade
i love the trades
pawn push i have a majority over here
let's get them rolling i can maybe grab
the apon
close to grabbing the apon let's get
more development in pawn push king f7 i
don't want to castle
let's stop this my knight wants to be
maintained on f5 i don't need to watch
over that t take towards the center so
my pawn watches over these two now this
pawn is dropping and i'm on the bishop
at the end of it and maybe even trap the
rook if the knight moves
let's come here
defend defend defend with check
grab
here and now get my king up my rooks are
connected
oh and i dropped a pawn
yeah you might want to hang onto that
pond next time
next time you might want to hang on to
that guy
oh let's go here i don't want that
bishop to take
or i could have just pinned the bishop
let's throw in a check it's got to be
uncomfortable
uh oh tricky knights everywhere
can i do that
more tricks
more tricks
i just take that this isn't even doing
anything
oh man i gotta even get my bishop
oh man
oh wait wait wait wait take here with
check defend that pawn just in the nick
of time
i unfortunately have enough time oh i
have that
watch out for the mates
watch out for the mates a bunch of
checks thrown in sneaky night sneaky
night
sneaky night has to be taken he's not
taking its mate back to tournament six
whoa 16 12 10 9 9 9 i'm in 11th 25
minutes remain
here we go
no e4
let's roll here bishop c4 d3 f4 knight
f3
are they going to converge on f2 i
should probably get rid of this um
okay this is good i have a 2-1 majority
in the center i might want to just sack
um some pieces
or sack a pawn i meant
okay is the knight gonna making a play
here yes he is
give me the g file
something needs to be done okay i have
this uh opened up let's get that bishop
out of there and then make use of
this right here i'm okay with this
structural damage i'm on h6
i got h6 i could take that pawn if the
pawn moves
i feel like i should just take that but
i'm not going to
okay this is trouble the king can't go
here there's
me very close
very close to happening queen cannot
take that pawn
it's at this night very difficult to
defend pawn push okay that's me
that's me back to tournament
23 17 16 12 12 12
24 minutes remaining
a lot of time
a lot of time remaining
a lot of ground to still make up though
a lot of points to be gained still
all right oh that pawn is gonna push no
he's not let's open this up over here
let's get more pieces out
okay they're ready to build a center i'm
ready to go in the center here pawn push
my knight weasels around in this
direction
and
let's get this pawn push in or
stop this advance for a little bit
get my a pawn rolling if this pawn
pushes i take here i'm up a pawn
i think it's a well it's a very
significant one
okay and i'll take here now this bishop
is a fairly dead piece but i still might
want to take him and then put pressure
on this pawn
or fork let's go with the fork instead
and i'm not going to take if the knight
moves i'll take this guy that's better
instead being up the exchange i'm just
up a piece
and as far as castling is concerned okay
well first off let's get this knight out
of here
bad stuff is just bound to happen if
he's around okay now i'm up a rook
i know i'm up to minor pieces it feels
like a rook though
feels like a rook
all right
let's watch over that pond uh there had
to be something cleaner here
okay i'm on that night
i'm on that night he's gonna go here
nope
okay clock situation i have i have a
time edge
take my rook
anything
this game is not going to
finish anything
game is not going to finish
time burners
time burners time burners back to
tournament 20
35 26 25 20's
all right virgin
is this one gonna start yes i'm having
to play all these games now
oh man not like the last tournament
right
last tournament was what
last tournament was all about
non-movers and quick resigners i really
didn't want to have to do that to my
knight but
we're gonna do that
the knight is without a great home isn't
he
take my bishop first
oh he's gotta go home
he's gotta go home or to a square that's
not so great
take my bishop first
okay
trouble gotta take with the f
gobble
gobble and then get my bishop on that
diagonal
that's got to be mate it is going to be
mate
the pawn has to push and then it's mate
right here that's game back to
tournament 30
38 35 30 gained a little bit of ground
anton squared
boom defend against the mate threat
watch out for the mate bishop c4 no
no soup for you
that's my defense no no soup for you
defense
no scholars mate for you
no scholars mate for you defense
okay okay you had your fun you had your
fun get rid of that light square bishop
he's just bad news
he's just bad news
what is this gonna be like happening
every time now
see anton i start going into a laughing
fit is that what's gonna happen
i gotta get him back gotta get him back
come on
he got me on f2 maybe i could get g2
whoa
whoa take with the knight you know you
want to take with the knight
he didn't take with the knight
just want to trade can we trade please
move knight
oh
slick
no that's not slick i was thinking the
rook was trapped
oh man let's come over here can we do
that please can we just do that
please
i want to keep my queen on the board
though
i feel like she wants to like do some
damage she can't really let's come here
the queen's not on the board i can't get
scholars mated
there
convincing enough right there isn't it
the queen's not on the board you can't
scholars mate me
what is that night up to he's up to no
good he's up to no good opposite color
bishops are
drawn
no they're not
not this one
not this one
give me this
pac-man
we can still get back rank mated maybe
better not happen it better not happen
oh take a bishop he's free he's still
free throwing a check
on percent or mate maybe back to
tournament 52
49 47 a lot of 40s
run forest
let's go forest
let's go forrest i have to come up with
some forrest gump lines or a quick mate
on f7
it was sniffed out
i'm trying more anton square tactics
right there hang on that's a nice hole
i'm going to jump into it
let's jump into that
oh
uh-oh holes holes light squares light
square invasion
what's that even mean
oh i didn't want to trade really i
didn't want to trade that was a slick
move
let me take that pawn and then pin the
knight and then attack the knight later
after the king goes there to f7 which is
the only square pile up on the weak link
pile up
he's cooked
right here support point for the knight
looking for mate in three
unavoidable three
potentially
one
has to take no the knight has to go here
that's the main four
the knight going to defend
yes and now nothing to do
back to tournament 56
65 56 56 17 minutes and change
i mentioned my way up there
a lot of time remaining
benko or no this is what blumenfeld
blumenfeld land
bloomfield gambit
i haven't played this much
uh oh
is it gonna be trouble
it might be trouble
knight's going to get kicked away
uh open lines
open lines this could turn out to be
very dangerous very soon how soon very
soon
very soon the king is running for the
hills
he is definitely running for the hills
why'd i do that
why
okay i could do that now the bishop
could have taken with check
let's take here bishop check here is
close to me
let's throw that in
where's the mate
the bishop's going to give a check
ah
oh why can't i find something good here
let's throw another check in see what
happens
i'm just going to give up my knight can
i do that and get away with it he's not
taking it
there had to be some just take this pun
oh let's come over here i should have
taken that pond sooner
man i probably missed a hundred things
by
now pins let's play here okay this has
to be good now
this has to be good now take that
pins i'm on the night
let's come here forks
i throw in a fork
watch out for that tricky night
i'm on the rook pawn push next okay this
is
this is a big trouble now
get that knight out of there hit that
rook let's throw in a check and then
take here
where is that mate oh i probably had oh
this would have been a nice one
i'm missing so much
it's just
this is so bad i better just at least
win can i throw a check in
okay win this rook at least
this this game isn't even going to
finish
that game
yeah man was he getting a workout he was
running around like crazy town
all right carol conland
no i'm not gonna take that time
i played that last time
are we gonna have that we are i'm gonna
grab that pun i'm okay with that they're
not
it's queen side castle and then jump in
here support my knight
all right let's get this advance in
right here make that a weakness maybe
on the bishop potentially
tricky bishop
tricky bishop
watch out my bishop wants to eye that b8
square very soon
be scared be very scared
i might want to kick that queen out of
there for this case i want to keep the
queens on the board i think
i think i think i think let's back up
the queen trade again i might want to
avoid the queen trade again why am i
doing all these things
can i do that and get away with it let's
back up i might want to throw a check in
if queen here
i could do that is the knight going to
post up there
no he's not
let's get a flight square
everybody loves a flight square
let's do what
um
i'm stuck with the plan
i want to maintain maintain control of
this file here
can i get that rook
clock situation is pretty decent can i
throw in some checks let's get that
knight out of there
i gotta defend here where is that mate
oh there's gonna be a queen trade queen
trade happening soon or is it
a queen check
okay i'll go for this where is that mate
let's throw a check in and then go here
where is the defense
queen's off
clock situation is what
just take that oh
clock situation's pretty good
tricky night tricky night tricky night i
got the night he's no longer tricky he's
dead
no longer tricky he's dead
have fun dancing with the queens dancing
queen variation
oh back to tournament that was a draw
whoa
i had so much material why wasn't i
going for me i thought i had more time
ah
oh what does that place mean i'm in 10th
i had so much material oh i thought oh
the queen there was a little glitch
there wasn't there
oh
man
i had so much material on that one
ah man
why didn't i go for a kill
why wasn't i going for a kill on that
one
i thought i was just gonna be able to
time burn my way
to victory lane
it was not happening though
it was not happening
okay
focus here
focus
on f2
everybody's favorite square in a chess
game is f2
f2 for the win
um
why am i not moving
a brain cramp right there that's what
you call a brain cramp
when you're just staring at the board
there and you just don't know what to do
oh boy
this is getting dangerous
very dangerous tricky nights and
everything
this is dangerous i have that covered
though
oh they missed it
they're getting the piece back though
let's give a check did they know that
that was there
they did
they did let's go here and then there
man i should have just tried to win that
one that was bad
that was so beat that was so big
tricky stuff
where are the tricks
they're going into uh
a crouch there
they're crouching
all right the king has to take maybe i
should have done this
first
all right stop in your tracks
i get that
this
timely checks
time burners in this one is it okay back
to tournament 136. i'm at 90 10 minutes
and change come on let's go i need quick
sneaky tactics
sneaky tactics that's not a good tactic
oh no
more sneaky tricks
get out of there night i need to do some
sneaky stuff take my knight or something
ugh
okay
can i somehow get it to that square
can i get there
pawn push
mate in one threat
oh
oh knight takes there no they gave it
back the knight could have gone there
i'll end up in a fork or a pin i don't
know what i'm saying
oh man yes free bishops for everybody
forex i still can't do that i'll end up
in a pin didn't you learn the first time
now it's there
oh what a disaster man what a disaster
man one draw and you're all the way
backed up like that
it just happens like that huh watch out
for forks there's a fork for you
everybody loves a fork go ahead okay
regroup
get over here that's where you belong
you need a flight square remember that
note to self you need a flight square
no let's not open up that diagonal
towards my king
sneak attack no
just avoid that
okay
okay give me this give me give me give
me give me give me
just give me that rook
oh no are you kidding me a mouse lip oh
no
no no no no no no no no no no no no it's
just going to be mate run run run run
run run run fast run fast please just
run fast oh no run over here it's safe
over here isn't it is it safe over here
no no no no no
how much time how much time
save the day save the day save the day
run over here you can't grab all my
pawns can you oh no no no what a
terrible mouse slip
over here please don't get mated don't
get mated don't get mated don't get
mated
ah
he's gonna grab that pun it's gonna be
another draw at the very least
he's gonna grab that pawn he should grab
that pawn shouldn't he no he's gonna
mate me
he's gonna mate me is he gonna make me
he is gonna beat me
i could cross over here just in time oh
no there's a hundred queens on the board
he's gonna make this very painful on me
there's four queens attack it's a four
queens attack
yes i got it they resign no they're dead
they're down on time my one pawn beats
28 points no that's bad math that's bad
math it's nine times one nine times four
that's 36 don't try to do math during
these bullet tournaments
oh
man
okay i sort of redeemed myself i sort of
did wow one pun beats oh there goes a
rook
there goes a pond there was a queen
check i'm in a pin
oh man
oh the one pond was holding his ground
wow was he a tough guy
wow now actually i just don't feel as
bad as that draw that i shouldn't have
had as a draw
give a check give a check let's go here
don't you dare run away
don't you dare
let's give a check here
oh man i got the queen the lady is dead
whoa my opponent was getting too excited
about getting material
wow
that was
nuts my one pun
what a fighter what a fighter he was huh
what a fighter let me tell you he was
one fighter let's grab here go here and
then mate in two if it's taken
mate in two or three
uh-oh
b-2 happening just resigned this is the
california kid
the california kid is not resigning oh
a nona friar
oh man
this guy is a member of the friars club
there all righty back to tournament 1
30. i'm lucky if i get on a
top 10. i'm struggling for top 10 this
is the guy is this the guy
or the girl or somebody who had the four
queens the four queens attack
i think
i better win this one or maybe i could
try to win it back with four queens
make sure i get rid of all my opponent's
pawns get rid of all their pawns first
whatever you do
get rid of them before they kill you
oh boy
all right let's come back i'm scared
let's come over here let's come over
here all right that's enough
that's enough of your sneakiness i'm on
the queen they should be scared
shouldn't they
i'm on the queen the queen is dead
i'm one queen up should i go for three
more i might want to get three more just
for fun just for fun in this one
redeem myself
this is the person right
it feels like it is
i'm not gonna get top three so let's try
to get uh like four queens
right
let's try and get four queens that is
the plan
now let's just go for a quick win
let's win the game
don't be fancy quit trying to get fancy
just win the game
where is that king going
where is he going
what am i doing
just win the game
why am i not trying to win okay this is
maitland isn't it maitland
my queen is hit
oh let's take here maintain two
right here
right here
boom 150
4 and change 208 200 184
can't believe that game i just can't
believe it you just never know what
you're gonna get
right where's forrest gump where's
forrest gump now now that i'm recalling
a line from forrest gump
right
chess game right war zones box of
chocolates you know what i was getting
at
oh man
you never know what you're gonna get if
you only have what
if you only have a pawn your opponent
has four queens
yeah
yeah bye now i know my knight is
brilliant isn't he he's going home
oh no oh no no no no no no no no no no
no
i gotta give up the queen
oh this is dangerous i gotta take that
knight he's got to go i cannot deal with
him
queen is dead queen is dead i'm
struggling to stay afloat
i'm struggling take pieces am i going to
go on castle yes it's official
officially on uncastled but what do i
have i have tricky nights
i have tricky nights
okay
i don't want to really open that file
let's go here and wait around a little
bit
i need to be a time burning expert right
now
can i sneak over here without anything
bad happening
let's do that are they going to do that
they might maybe they should now i'll do
that now do that sneakiness sneakiness
now while maybe they can't double or
something
don't take my night whatever you do
i need my knight oh pigs pigs beware the
pigs throwing some checks time burners
around the corner time burners over here
sneaky rooks
my knight is holding down the fort
i don't really want to trade i'm gonna
have to trade
no i don't i have to trade maybe
okay i'll take this one and then throw
in a check and then just come back here
everybody loves doing that don't they
taking pieces like that and then running
away scared
can i sneak away my knight wants to be
on f5
sneakiness time burners oh they gave
back the queen
i got it they're down on time
back to tournament 170
147 145 one minute 45 remaining
wow there are a lot of people up there
and i'm not one of them 139 can i sneak
another one in
barely can i sneak another one in 134
watch out for f2
sound like i'm yelling at myself i'm
really not i promise i don't do that
okay i got a pond why'd i take with the
pond why ruin my structure like that
that was stupid they can't take here
because of an eventual pin
i can maybe grab this pond but there
might be uh pins here
let's pile up pawn push pawn push
uh oh sneak attack
it's a sneak attack i'm on the queen
let's trade get the f-file maybe get
this pun or something
it's castle just take my bishop would
you
clock situation where are you at there
might be main two main two possibilities
move night move night anywhere anywhere
anywhere just anywhere you want to go
anywhere you want to go
here i take you and then here
i just want that knight to move can you
move please
yes he moved power of suggestion strikes
seventh 190 35
34 33
mont
what do we have here
okay i need a quick win if there's gonna
be a quick win it has to happen soon how
soon
there's not gonna be anything happening
on this side of the board
okay there's the clock right here
right here it'll get in the way of my a
pawn a little bit
um let's take like this let's put it up
here there's no pieces there
right here right here i need a quick win
i got to do anything oh they're sniffing
it out oh there goes my queen
don't make me finish this one please
whatever you do don't make me finish
this one call it
throw in the towel for me yes
saved by the bell
thanks for playing
oh man
eighth
you see
much different from that last tournament
i should have had
ah the one dry had i should have what
good games all
i should have
won
in the game i should have lost
the one with the four queens versus a
pawn
oh man
do i even have to say i should have lost
that one that was craziness
whoa